at the very last minute Apple has
apparently canceled the single biggest
feature of the upcoming iPhone 15 Pro
but due to some conflicting rumors from
different leakers there's a chance that
at least part of it is going to be
happening for real so let's jump right
into it just the other day Ming shikwo a
very reliable Apple leaker said that
iPhone 15 Pro Models will no longer
feature solid state buttons even saying
that apple is going to be delaying it
until the iPhone 16 Pro due to design
issues at the very last minute and this
is crazy because Apple apparently
ordered specific parts for this new
design change and feature but now they
are scrappian now I've been doing some
research to try to figure out exactly
which parts of this new feature are
getting delayed and which ones are
staying and thankfully we got a final
major leak that confirms it all but
before I get into that I've got you the
back story to the solid state button
leaks way back in October of 2022 main
Chico said that the iPhone 15 Pro Models
will feature solid state buttons and
three taptic engines which he talks
about in his leak thread right here
saying that the two additional taptic
engines are going to be right there
where the volume rocker is and for the
power button so instead of physical
buttons they're going to be basically
solid non-movable but when you touch it
it's going to sense the touch and then
vibrate and it's going to feel like a
click just like Apple's magic Force
touch trackpad or touch ID and then the
awesome thing is that back in February
Max Weinbach released the official case
cads for the iPhone 15 Pro and here he
even showed off a completely different
action button right here instead of the
mute switch and one unified button for
the volume rocker and then the YouTuber
zone of tech actually looked at these
cats when he was trying to make renders
and he noticed that the actual buttons
have two pins on them meaning that
they're getting fully redesigned and
there's only going to be one single
volume rocker and then of course we got
even more leaks like this CAD that was
posted on the Chinese version of tick
tock and on Twitter by shrimp Alpha Pro
confirming this new design with the
action button replacing the mute switch
and then we got even more details from a
Mac Rumors Forum user who said that it's
going to feature a multi-use action
button instead of the mute switch so
you're going to be able to program it to
open different apps and do different
things kind of like the triple tap on
the back feature that iPhones have right
now like you can see this whole list of
things they could potentially do that is
really nice and they even said that the
iPhone 15 Pro is going to have a new low
energy chip that will allow allow the
solid state buttons to work when the
device is off or out of battery so brand
new technology that'll fix all of the
concerns that people had with the solid
state buttons that's going to fix it no
problem at all and then even better
Elite came out saying that there can be
button sensitivity that can be
customized to cater for different cases
and gloves so yes that means case
support will still work even with those
new solid-state buttons but then of
course we just got this leak saying that
it is canceled it's not happening until
the iPhone 16 Pro however we have some
alternative viewpoints from different
leakers for example revegnness Tech
Reeve on Twitter said that the solid
state button canceling mass production
is a fake rumor to catch insiders so
apparently Apple has already ordered all
of the parts so they're definitely
coming according to Tech Reeve and
saying that apple is just trying to
catch out their leaking sources and that
kind of adds up because we had this
dummy iPhone 15 pro model surface which
showed the new action button and the
unified volume rocker which is really
cool and then once again of course we
had the cads the case cads that match up
showing off this new design and then we
had unknowns 21 a very reliable leaker
say that so far he hasn't seen anything
to suggest a different exterior design
for the buttons saying that the iPhone
15 Pro is in the EVT stage so it's
nearing production but he said although
changes are always possible and then
guess what just this morning he showed
off a full render showing the internal
components and how the new volume button
is going to work and you can see right
here the Mac Rumors article and there
you go there is the button he even had a
video on YouTube show off that there's
basically a slit right down the middle
of this unified volume rocker to help
people see where the plus and minus will
be it's going to help differentiate it
and that totally makes sense and you can
see it in this video right here but even
crazier he also shared this video of the
actual component that will connect
everything together showing off the new
action button right there then you have
the volume rocker then on the other side
the power button this is the component
or part that will be used and it looks
like it's totally legit I'm not sure how
he gained access to this but this
totally makes sense and then somebody on
Twitter asked him are the haptic buttons
still a thing on the 15 Pro and he said
current info suggests so but finally he
just released an update to his leak and
apparently all of that is scrapped it
turns out mean she quo was right and his
leak that he just did saying that it's
getting delayed and now unknown's 21
also agrees that the iPhone 15 Pro is
gonna be featuring a two button design
for volume just like before but
thankfully there is a silver lining
because he has confirmed that the mute
switch will get replaced by a button so
yes the 16 year old mute switch we've
had since the original iPhone we are
getting a new action button instead and
that is confirmed so that is really
really good news but as far as the solid
state buttons it's getting delayed it's
not happening and the single unified
button not happening either just the
action button and then here we can see
that Uno 21 gave us an up update saying
unfortunately right as they were in the
middle of releasing the existing design
he received confirmation of the plan
changes to the 15 Pro it happens they
did all that work they made those two
videos all those renders just for it to
be abruptly canceled so ming chikuo was
right and even though he made these and
they're canceled they are going to be
coming next year so at least we have
these for next time around so with that
said let me know what you think about
that leak down in the comment section
below click the circle of us to
subscribe for more videos check out one
of those two right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]